découvre l'histoire de Paul Rousset
sabaghina gérant du plus bel hôtel de
Kigali l'hôtel des Mille Collines à la
veille du génocide Rwanda 1994 hôtel de
luxe qu'il transforme en refuge quand
les violences intercommunautaires
éclatent Paul Rousset
la vie de plus de 1000 Tutsis promis une
mort certaine sous le regard impuissant
des casques bleus avec le général Roméo
Dallaire à leur taille
il passera les années suivantes à
partager son parcours et donner des
conférences comme ici au Canada en 2006
mais coup de théâtre il est arrêté
illégalement à Dubaï en 2020 et ramenait
de force au Rwanda pour y être accusé de
terrorisme sa fille réclame alors à la
Belgique d'intervenir pour faire libérer
et rapatrier son père qui possède la
nationalité belge et dénonce les
circonstances de son arrestation la
décision de le kidnapper de le mettre
dans un avion privé pour l'année de
force au Rwanda montre que leur
eux-mêmes ne crois pas dans leur dans la
légitimité de leur des preuves contre
lui
malgré les protestations et les
dénonciations internationales Paul
Rousset sabaghina est condamné en 2021 à
25 ans de prison sa libération demain et
le résultat d'une Clémence accordée par
la justice rwandaise le héros national a
dû signer une lettre promettant de ne
pas se lancer en politique et de quitter
le pays pour toujours ici lise
Villeneuve Radio-Canada Montréal